على الاسرائيليين ان يفهموا انهم ما لم
يقبلوا وينخرط في عمليه سلام حقيقيه تؤدي
بعد هذه المعركه الملحميه في غزه الى منح
الفلسطينيين حقوقهم الاساسيه في دولتهم
المستقله وعلى حدود الرابع من حزيران فان
الحرب هذه لن تنتهي وانهم اذا سكتت
المدافع لمده شهر سنه او سنتين فسوف تعود
الى
الانفجار
على الاسين تعلموا بعد حوالي عشره حروب
بينهم وبين العرب على اقل تقدير ومنها ست
حروب او مع مع حماس ان يتذكروا بان هذه
هذا الامر سوف يستمر وان القضا على حماس
وضرب من الخيال والامر الثالث انه هم اكثر
ناس يخلقون ويساهم في خلق الجنود حماس
الذين يحاربونه ويقولون عنهم انهم
ارهابيون اذا لابد من ان تتخلص اسرائيل من
هذه الحكومه المتطرفه التي لم تعد تصلح لا
في في اي زمان ولا في اي مكان في هذا
العالم المنكود وكذلك علينا ان نعلم نحن
ان العرب ان نتعلم من دروس الماضي وان
نتوحد في كلمتنا حتى لا
يكون تكون دوله ما عربيه هي الضحيه
القادمه وتؤكل كما اكل الثور الابيض امام
هذه الحقائق كلها اذا لابد اولا من اجماع
عربي على الاقل بين الدول ذات العلاقه
المباشره
اي مع القضيه الفلسطينيه وهي الاردن ومصر
وطبعا السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وبعد ذلك
تاتي على دول الخليج او مجموعه من دول
الخليج ذات الاهميه وكذلك لابد ان يكون
هنالك ايضا تفهم لدى اسرائيل
بان لابد من والفلسطينيين اقصد ان يكون
هنالك استعداد كامل للخوض في مفاوضات جاده
مبنيه على دراسات على خرائط على حقائق
ثابته على مناورات سياسيه وان يكون الهدف
واضحا تماما العمليه السلميه لن تكون سهله
وكثير من الناس يثيرون حكايه الامر الواقع
يعني يقولون كيف س نصل الى سلام لم يبقى
من ارض فلسطين شيئا كثرت ال كثر
المستوطنون وال المستعمرون الاسرائيليون
في الضفه الغربيه وبلغ عددهم حوالي 700000
وكذلك يتحدثون عن ان هنا ان هنالك حوالي
كذا مستوطنه فكيف س يعني يستطيع
الفلسطينيون بناء دوله متصله ا قابله
للحياه اذا بقيت هذه المستوطنات بالعكس هي
العمليه السلميه كلها يجب ان تنصب على
عمليه انهاء هذه وتصفيه هذه البرامج
الاسرائيليه في الارض لكي تبتلعها وانه
اذا تو بقيت هنالك مشاكل عالقه امام
المستوطنات الكبيره فهذه يمكن مقايضتها او
شرائها او اتفاق عليها هنالك حقوق كبيره
جدا للفلسطينيين عند الاسرائيليين فيما
يتعلق باللاجئين فلذلك ليست هنالك مشكله
ضخمه كما يقولون ان التفاوض والدراسات
العلميه والمتينه والموقف الصامد العربي
يستطيع من خلال التفاوض ان يقنع العالم
بان لديه قضيه
اساسيه ويجب ان تحل من اجل مصلحه العالم
كله والمنطقه الحساسه من العالم التي نحي
فيها الامر الاخير قطعا هو التي سيقف في
الطريق هي قضيه القدس قضيه القدس من
القضايا المعقده والاردن يجب ان يكون
شريكا في هذا التفاوض حولها لان الاردن
يملك حق الوصايه الهاشميه منذ 100 عام على
الاماكن المقدسه الاسلاميه والمسيحيه
بتوافق مع الكنائس المسيحيه ليس مع
اسرائيل ومن هنا فانني اعتقد بانه هذا
الامر ايضا امر القدس وادعاءات اسرائيل
حوله يجب ان تحل وان يكون هنالك حق
للمسلمين في استعاده هذه الاراضي مع
الحفاظ على حريه العباده اما فيما يتعلق
بموضوع اللاجئين كما قلت حق العوده هو
النقطه الاساسيه
ا يقولون ان حق العوده مقابله مقابل قانون
العوده قانون العوده اي من هو الذي وضع
قانون العوده الذي وضعهم الاسرائيليون
انفسهم اصحاب المصلحه المباشره في هذه
القضيه اما حق اما حق العوده بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين فهو حق معترف به دوليا لكل
الشعوب التي تهجر من اراضيها يج هي قادره
على العوده ومن حقها ان تعود الى اراضيها
ولذلك لابد من ان تتفهم اسرائيل هذه
القضايا وان ندعمها بالموقف القوي العربي
وان يكون هنالك تنسيق ثالثا اداره
المفاوضات في المره القادمه يجب ان لا
تكون محصوره فقط في كل الامور على على
المقابلات الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه انما
يجب ان يكون هنالك شركاء عرب لهم مص مصلحه
مباشره في هذا واخص الاردن ومصر بالذات
لانه فيما يتعلق بقضايا الضفه الغربيه
وغزه هنالك دول لها مصالح استراتيجيه كبرى
وبخاصه الاردن ومن هنا مثل قضيه الترسيم
الحدود قضيه الترتيبات الامنيه قضيه
اللاجئين كما ذكرت لان الاردن استضاف اكبر
عدد من اللاجئين واخيرا وليس اخرا
قضيه الحقوق واللاجئين ولم يخرج من الاردن
لاجئين الى اسرائيل كما حصل في بعض الدول
العربيه اذا نحن امام حقائق يجب ان نعرفها
بالتفصيل وان نرسم
مسارا صحيحا بالتعاون مع دول العالم التي
تقف معنا امريكا اذا لم ترد ان تدخل وبقيت
معلقه بموقفها الحالي سواء كان جمهوريه
الاداره جمهوريه ام ديمقراطيه هذا لن
ينفعنا وعلينا دائما ان نتعاون مع دول
اخرى والا فان البديل سيكون حروبا مستمره
حتى
تستطيع اسرائيل ان تفهم انه ما في دوله
ولا قوه اجت الى هذه المنطقه الا اما ذابت
فيها او خرجت منها هذا هو الخيار امام
اسرائيل وعليها ان تعرف ان التاريخ يقف
الى جانبنا وفي النهايه لا بد ان نذكر
قضيه اساسيه وهي من يمثل الشعب الفلسطيني
في التفاوض هل هي السلطه الفلسطينيه ام هي
منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه انا اقول بان
السلامه يجب ان يتم مع
جميع المنظمات
الفلسطينيه التي تجمعها مظله واحده هي
مصدر تنبع عنها كل الترتيبات الاخرى وهي
منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه ولذلك يجب ان
ندخل التفاوض في اطار منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه حتى يكون القرار ممثلا لجميع
فئات الشعب الفلسطيني حسب معتقداتهم
السياسيه او اختلاف ارائهم ولكنهم في
النهايه موحدون انهم يعملون تحت ظلت
المنظمه منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه وهي
صاحبه الدور الاساس في اي تفاوض
مستقبلي